[Música]
son las 9:29 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna que seguimos
comentándoles los principales hechos del
día Les agradecemos su sintonía y vamos
con los titulares de esta jornada
el presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
confirmó que fueron hallados con vida
los cuatro menores que desaparecieron el
pasado Primero de Mayo y de los que no
se tuvo noticia en 40 días los niños se
perdieron en una densa selva del
suroccidente colombiano luego de que la
aeronave la que viajaban se estrellara
ampliamos en estudio
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump se enfrenta a 37 cargos en medio
de la investigación por los documentos
clasificados que fueron hallados en su
residencia de Florida dos de sus
abogados dimitieron hoy se espera que
otros expertos se unan a su defensa en
los próximos días
en Reino Unido el ex Primer Ministro
Boris Johnson renunció a su cargo como
diputado conservadora en la cámara de
los comunes según el exfuncionario el
comité que Investiga las fiestas en
Downey Street durante la pandemia te
dejó Claro que sería expulsado
Próximamente del parlamento
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos esta Informativo en Colombia
porque el presidente Gustavo Petro
confirmó que fueron hallados los cuatro
menores de 11 meses y cuatro nueve y
Trece años que estaban desaparecidos
desde el pasado Primero de Mayo en esa
fecha se perdió la avioneta cesna en la
que viajaban con su madre y otras dos
personas que se accidentó en una densa
selva del suroccidente del país para
ampliar este tema me acompaña en estudio
mi compañero lluís Muñoz bienvenido
usted estuvo en la zona informando sobre
este caso qué detalles se conocen un día
feliz Valentina y no estamos siempre
acostumbrados en Colombia dar este tipo
de noticias como un rescate que es ya
milagroso e histórico para el país han
sido 40 días como bien comentaba usted
en una selva donde llueve 16 horas al
día siempre es de noche y nunca antes
había sido explorada por el nombre es
por eso que es tan espectacular que unos
niños hayan podido sobrevivir allá gusta
ministro del presidente de Colombia
llegó a llegó a Colombia precisamente
después de estar en Cuba esta mañana
firmando un acuerdo de cese al fuego con
la guerrilla activa más antigua de
América Latina el eln y nada más llegar
se ha entero de la noticia ha dicho que
es un día mágico una palabra muy
importante en Colombia ha dicho que
están los niños en San José del guaviare
que según como vayan los chequeos
médicos se los va a poder trasladar a
Bogotá o a villavicencio donde están los
abuelos y familiares y vamos a escuchar
qué más ha dicho en su llegada aquí a
Bogotá Bueno hoy hemos tenido un día
mágico
que indudablemente llena de alegrías
acercarnos y tocar la paz
en el acuerdo que avanza con el eln y
ahora
regreso y la primera noticia es que
efectivamente las comunidades indígenas
que estuvieron en la búsqueda y la
fuerza militares conjuntamente
encontraron a los niños 40 días después
estaban solos habían sido ellos mismos
lograron un ejemplo de sobrevivencia
total digamos que quedará en la historia
así que esos niños son hoy los niños de
la paz y los niños de Colombia eran las
palabras del presidente Gustavo Petro
nosotros a esta hora conectamos con
Astrid Cáceres ella es directora del
instituto colombiano de bienestar
familiar la entidad encargada de la
protección integral de la infancia en
Colombia Astrid bienvenida France 24 lo
primero que queremos saber cómo están
los niños
sé que están bien sé lo que dijo el
presidente efectivamente lo van a
revisar en una ambulancia meditalizada y
dependiendo de eso sino para Bogotá
Bueno sobre todo sé que que tenemos que
tener un compromiso para cuidarlos
profundamente en este país que tenemos
que lograr que por cada niño se mueva al
mundo y que podamos hacerlo como lo
hicimos en este caso realmente estoy muy
feliz estoy en carretera
riohacha allá a Santa Marta hasta que
estaba en una ranchería en maicao y
recibir la noticia ya y saber que cada
cosa que hagamos tiene que tener impacto
es para mí maravilloso
astrito usted está ahora en el norte del
país en el Caribe nosotros coincidimos
en San José del guaviare en calamar en
plena selva y estuvimos conversando
sobre la importancia de esta misión como
ha dicho Queríamos saber quién los
encontró Y qué es lo primero que han
podido saber de mano de los niños sobre
cómo han podido sobrevivir
en general está con toda la información
del detalle Yo realmente no he logrado
la comunicación que quisiera para saber
el nivel de detalle de lo que pasó en
este momento
sé lo mucho de lo que hablamos y que
había que recoger parte de esta historia
porque realmente son unos niños muy
particulares y es muy importante lo que
está pasando pero el nivel de detalle
cómo nos encontraron el general y lo
tiene la tropa y La tropa indígena que
está allá pero yo no he podido lograr
comunicación con ellos haciendo
referencia otra vez al encuentro que
tuvimos en calamar en la base aérea
desde donde han salido los indígenas los
militares y donde También usted estuvo
en en el terreno usted me dijo que
confiaban mucho desde el gobierno en las
creencias ancestrales
Sí es que es que aquí hay que confiar
muchísimo en La Voz de las familias en
la forma como el corazón no Uno guiando
y como también eso mezclado con la
sabiduría indígena y con la sabiduría
militar tenía que dar resultados
realmente Esa fue siempre la esperanza
pero no se vale solo la táctica militar
sino hay un corazón con las familias
sino hay una conexión con sus creencias
y creo que esa fue la apuesta que
hicimos bueno el 17 de mayo pasado
Gustavo Petro tuiteo que se habían
encontrado estos niños no Un día después
borró el tuitter y dijo que había sido
una información errónea desde su
institución Cómo terminó este episodio
Perdón un segundo porque es que me están
llamando presidencia un segundo
son las cosas del directo Valentina
tenemos que recordar que desde las
instituciones militares se han Unido con
los indígenas algo inédito que no era
muy habitual en Colombia donde estas
organizaciones como la guardia indígena
estaban más acostumbradas a estar
enfrentadas con los militares en
terrenos muy alejados pero se han Unido
y además se han encontrado todo tipo de
métodos para encontrar a los niños han
reproducido en lengua indígena mensajes
de la abuela se han lanzado paquetes de
comida se han lanzado flyers han puesto
silbatos se han llevado también perros
que Petro ha confirmado que Wilson uno
de los perros que se había perdido y que
se creía que podría estar con los niños
todavía no ha aparecido Bueno pues
esperamos que también Wilson aparezca
muy pronto Luisa usted muchas gracias
por esta ampliación Gracias Valentina un
lujo nosotros continuamos y vamos a
Estados Unidos el expresidente candidato
presidencial por el partido republicano
Donald Trump fue imputado con 37 cargos
por el Departamento de Justicia el
motivo es la presunta violación a
numerosas leyes relativas a la seguridad
Nacional del país después de que en
agosto de 2022 el FBI encontrará más de
100 documentos clasificados en la
residencia del exmandatario en mara lago
Trump ha afirmado su inocencia y ha
descrito el proceso legal como una
cacería de brujas ligado al partido
demócrata el informe es de Max Pérez
Gallardo
Donald Trump imputado por el
Departamento de Justicia las autoridades
estadounidenses dieron a conocer el acta
de acusación contra el expresidente
dicho documento indica que el también
Magnate enfrenta 37 cargos relativos a
la violación de leyes sobre seguridad
nacional El fiscal encargado del caso
Jack Smith reveló el informe donde se
incluyen los cargos contra Trump y
agregó que nadie está por encima de la
ley
al Estado de derecho es un principio
básico del departamento de justicia y el
compromiso de nuestra nación con el
estado de derecho es un ejemplo para el
mundo en este país tenemos un conjunto
de leyes que aplican para todo el mundo
el ahora precandidato republicano para
los comicios presidenciales de 2024 ha
arremetido en numerosas ocasiones contra
el fiscal Smith llegando a calificarlo
como un psicópata a través de una
publicación en la plataforma Truth
social de la cual Trump es propietario
en el mismo mensaje el expresidente
tilda la actual presidente
estadounidense Joe biden como un
criminal ha sido blanco de críticas en
las redes sociales de Trump que acusa al
presidente demócrata de utilizar al
departamento de justicia en su contra el
mandatario estadounidense ha expresado
que no ha hablado sobre Trump con la
cabeza del departamento de Justicia Mary
Garden
presidente biden ha hablado ya con el
fiscal general no he hablado con él en
lo absoluto no voy a hablar con él no
tengo ningún comentario sobre lo
ocurrido tras la revelación del acta
acusadora Trump está citado a comparecer
ante una corte en Miami el martes 13 de
junio el ex Primer Ministro británico
Boris Johnson deja su cargo como miembro
del parlamento con efecto inmediato lo
que provocará una elección Para ocupar
su escaño Johnson asegura que se vio
forzado a renunciar la decisión Está
vinculada al caso conocido como Party
Gates los detalles desde Londres con
Luisa Pulido
la sorpresiva renuncia de Boris Johnson
como diputado del partido conservador
del que fue jefe Hasta hace menos de un
año significa y se traduce en un momento
político bien importante para el Reino
Unido Johnson aduce que fue forzado a
tomar esta decisión porque el comité de
privilegios del parlamento que estaba
investigando si el ex Primer Ministro
había mentido deliberadamente al
parlamento a la cámara de los comunes
sobre el partygate según ha dicho
Johnson iba a ser forzado por la puerta
de atrás iba a ser forzado a salir en
una declaración de esta noche de
renuncia Johnson dice entre otras que el
único propósito de este comité de
privilegios desde el principio ha sido
encontrarme culpable independientemente
de los hechos Esta es la definición de
una corte canguro y agrega también en
otra parte que esto sienta un precedente
peligroso e inquietante la pregunta
ahora por supuesto es sí Boys Johnson
termina o no su carrera política porque
sin duda es uno de los hombres más
populares pero al mismo tiempo
controvertidos también por supuesto en
esta carta Johnson dice que se siente
muy triste dejar el parlamento por lo
menos por ahora y no da más pistas sobre
su carrera política Lo cierto es que esa
es la gran pregunta qué va a pasar ahora
con Boris Johnson especialmente de Cara
a las elecciones generales posiblemente
a finales del 2024 en el que Boris
Johnson era la gran Esperanza para su
partido en otras noticias en Ucrania
continúan las especulaciones sobre la
contraofensiva que para el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin ya comenzó sin
lograr éxito hasta el momento durante la
semana ha habido enfrentamientos en el
este y el sur del país pero las
autoridades ucranianas prefieren por
ahora hablar sobre los esfuerzos de
rescate después de la destrucción de la
presa de novaka del pasado 6 de junio
más en el siguiente informe
todavía no hay anuncios sobre la
contraofensiva de Ucrania pero sus
tropas están en movimiento el viernes un
convoy se trasladó hacia paccut ciudad
que ha estado en medio de un tira y
afloja entre las fuerzas ucranianas y
rusas también se informó de combates en
el sur cerca de saporilla la ciudad en
sí estaba tranquila sus residentes
alegres Y optimistas sobre la próxima
ofensiva
todos Lo estamos esperando cuanto antes
mejor
una contraofensiva es una contraofensiva
se siente bien se siente cálido es
conmovedor que poco a poco Comencemos a
liberar nuestros territorios los
territorios ucranianos
[Música]
la información sobre la contraofensiva
aún no se ha revelado por completo no
diré nada al respecto pero estoy
apoyando a nuestros soldados mis
familiares están participando en la
guerra Así que tengo a alguien a quien
apoyar Por quién esperar y orar
en Rusia el presidente Vladimir Putin
afirmó que la contraofensiva ha
comenzado pero sin logro significativos
de la fuerza sucranianas
podemos afirmar con certeza que esta
ofensiva ha comenzado se evidencia por
el uso de las reservas estratégicas del
ejército ucraniano
las tropas ucranianas no han logrado los
objetivos asignados esto es
absolutamente obvio
absoluta
pero las cosas se han complicado mucho
con la destrucción de La Represa de
novakahopka que inundado vastas
extensiones de tierra alrededor del Río
timipro el presidente
dijo que las autoridades estaban
haciendo todo lo posible para poner a la
gente a salvo quien asegura tener
evidencia de que Rusia destruyó La
Represa de La Era soviética para
obstaculizar la esperada contraofensiva
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llegan a Natalia Cabrera con toda
la información del continente americano
en aquí América feliz noche para todos